- [Interviewer] All right, Tony.
- [Tony] How's it going?
- [Interviewer] Tony,
where you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- My origin from Victorville, California.
San Bernardino County.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
both your parents growing up?
- I had both my parents growing up,
and just my father, he was
absent from most of my life.
He was in the military
and was very violent,
and he left my side about nine years old.
- [Interviewer] When you say
he left, where did he go?
- He went to prison, federal prison,
because he was manufacturing
drugs and stuff like that,
so, he was taken away from us.
- [Interviewer] And how was
your childhood otherwise?
- It was good.
I grew up as a Christian guy.
I was in the music industry
with a band and stuff,
Christian band, and that's what I did
with most of my childhood, was--
- [Interviewer] So religion was a big part
of your upbringing?
- Yeah, it was a part of my life.
It was a big part of my life,
and with my extra time, I
was doing my schoolwork,
and I was in track and
field, and wrestling,
and I had a pretty good childhood.
My mom, she was always devoted to us,
and she never really concentrated
anything else but us.
And all I can do is thank
my mom for raising us
to best way she could, you know?
There was six of us and single parent.
She went to school, she got educated,
and I don't know how she did it,
but a single mom, it would raise us all,
and we lived pretty poor,
you know what I mean?
A good meal for us was Top Ramen.
That's pretty much what it was.
Although it was tough for her,
and I appreciate her and I
know she had a hard time,
but my childhood was rough.
I was brought up fairly well as in,
I'm a 3.9 student.
I almost got my 4.0.
Like within all my
years, I was a good kid.
I was one of the best I could say
because that tool I would
always thrive for was,
I was really competitive.
I always wanted to be the best.
And I did that but, I made some decisions
along down the road which,
I became who I am today.
Some of my friends would ask me,
"What happened, what made that change?"
I made it, and now I got to live with it.
But, I can go from negative to positive.
Within my experiences that
I have experienced now,
I plan on somehow turning it into
like I see myself helping the
youth or anything like that.
Like now, within my experiences in prison
and the things that I went through,
I believe I can turn it
into something positive
and help other kids
that have the background
of the gang-life or drug use,
and all so forth like that.
That's what I plan on doing now
because this wasn't the plan,
but sometimes life throws
a curveball at you.
And somebody smart, he told me,
"Do you know the difference
"between a Major League Baseball player
"and a Minor League Baseball player?
"Well the Minor League
can't hit a curveball,
"but a Major League player
can hit that curveball."
So now that the ball is
thrown at me and it's a curve,
and it's a pretty fast one,
and now I got to learn how
to just swing it and hit it,
and that's what I'm doing today,
is trying to turn this bad experience
into something positive.
When I made this decision,
I don't know if I should go now with,
my story.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I was younger, and I was 18 years old,
and I came home one day.
Me and my buddies were
hanging out up at the house,
and I would go,
"Hey Rob, let me see your phone man
"because my phone's inside charging."
He looked a little bit
worried, but he's like,
"Here you go."
He passes me his phone and then he goes,
And I happen to notice
somebody kept texting him
and I'm like, "Huh, I wonder."
So I look over at his phone,
and I pick it up, and I look at the phone,
and I noticed it was my
baby sister's phone number.
And I was like, "What the fuck?"
So I started thinking to myself,
"Okay, should I be nosy?" or whatever,
so I grab it, and I click on it,
and it happens to be me my
baby sister texting this man.
And she was at the time only 13 years old,
and this man's 30,
and it happened to be about sexual things.
And it was like,
"Oh, you're bomb, you're this and that."
I mean it was consensual,
but at the same time, he manipulated her
into believing that they
would have a life somewhere
along the road and stuff like that.
And so it was shocking to me,
and a cold chill came up over me like,
"Oh my god, I can't believe this shit."
So, what I do is I look at him,
and I decided in that moment,
"Okay, I'm gonna get this guy."
So I'm like, "We need more drinks."
Because this guy was pretty
big, you know what I mean?
He was bigger than me,
so I'm like, "How in the
fuck am I gonna do this one?"
So, I came up with a quick plan,
and I was like, "Let's get him drunk."
So, we start drinking up in the garage,
and I got him pretty drunk,
and it came to that moment where,
my buddy, he was in the garage.
He looks at me, and I
already ran it down to him,
so, I hit the garage door,
and he knows somethings up
because he's like, "Oh, I
think I'm gonna go now."
And I'm like, "All
right, give me a second."
So I go inside, and I know
it gets a little graphic
and a little bad but, I grab my ice pick.
So, when he decides to leave,
he yawns like this, he goes,
"I'ma leave like this."
And when he did that yawn,
I stabbed him three times.
I stabbed him three times,
and after that, I started
just stomping him out,
and within that moment,
I thought of putting a can in his mouth.
So I put the can in his mouth like this,
and I kick it which dislocated
his jaw, to his mouth,
and the can went into his mouth.
And by this time, I thought he was dead.
- [Interviewer] When you say can--
- A can, a beer can.
- [Interviewer] Oh, a beer can.
- A complete full beer
can went into his mouth,
which I got up and just,
(pops mouth) into his mouth
and ripped his whole mouth open.
And by that time, he was pale white.
He wasn't breathing, I thought.
And I look over, my wife
opens the garage door,
and she's like, "Oh my god."
So when I go, "Get the fuck out."
And she shuts the door immediately,
and then, she comes back.
This is what's crazy.
This girl loved me so
much where she comes back
with rubber gloves and bleach,
and (chuckles) she started
cleaning up all the blood.
She's like freaking out.
She's like, "Oh my god
Tony, what are we gonna do?
"Like, what the hell,
why did you do this?"
And I'm like, "Just relax, relax."
So, I go grab the living room carpet.
We grab this guy, well I grab this guy.
Nobody else was involved,
I grabbed this guy,
and I start rolling him in the carpet.
- [Interviewer] The rug?
- The rug, the rug.
And, I drag this guy into my car,
throw him in the trunk,
and drive him out to
the middle of nowhere,
which was Barstow, in the desert.
And by this time, this man still out cold,
and I toss him out.
And God, somebody up there
must have loved this guy
because for this man to
actually get back up,
from whatever I did,
and I thought I got away with it
because I'm in my living room.
This a little long down
the road, a month later.
I thought I got away with it.
Everybody's calling me,
"Hey, have you seen Robert?"
And I'm like, "Nah, I haven't seen him."
My brother's like,
"Hey Tony, you're the last one with him,
"and his family keeps calling us."
And I'm like, "Pft, I have no idea."
And all these charges, I've
already been convicted of.
So there's no any crime
here because I did my time.
So, his family's calling, and
I thought I got away with it,
and next thing you know,
I'm sitting back in my
room, my living room,
and my door gets kicked in.
It's the cops.
The cops come in, and they're like,
"You know why we're here."
And I'm like, "No, I don't do anything."
So, they come in and they're like,
"We're here because you're
last seen with Robert Lopez."
And this is where they got me, is that,
I was like, "I thought
that dude was gone."
And they're like, "No, he's been in ICU.
"He's been in an intensive
care, Hi-Desert Hospital."
And I was like, "Oh, okay,
and so why are you guys here?"
And they look at me and they're like,
"You really don't know?"
I'm like, "I have no clue."
"Well Robert Lopez said
that you were with him last,
"and that you hurt him."
And by that time, I was
like, "Okay, I'm fucked."
But, I went along with it,
and I said I had no idea,
but I did incriminate myself
by saying "I was with him."
And this is where it starts.
They arrest me, I go to jail.
And within that time in jail,
my first deal on the table was 25 to life
because they got me for pre-meditated
and torturing a victim.
So, I was looking at 25 to life,
and within that time, I
fought it for 16 months.
I was lucky to get a celly
that was all about law,
and he says, "You know what, Tony?
"You shouldn't be reading
them stupid books."
I was reading a lot of James Patterson,
all those crazy books and stuff and,
he tells me, "You should read more stuff
"that gets you out of
here, which was law."
So I started learning
more about law and stuff.
So, I learned that, and when
I went into the courtroom,
and this is further along down,
which, I'ma try to speed it up for you.
I went the second time to court,
and then they're like,
"Mr.Michaels, well we got a deal
"on the table for you right now.
"If you sign 40 years, we'll
take the life sentence off."
And I was like, "Well,
can I waive some time
"because I need to think about this,
"and I need to talk to my wife."
And I didn't know they
were still investigating me
because they wanted to see if I was crazy
or if I had a different motive,
because I did explain
to 'em what happened,
he molested my little sister and stuff.
And what got me out was, he had a phone.
The victim had the phone,
and I kept it
because to be honest, I was gonna sell it,
cluck it, whatever you want to call it.
You know what I mean?
I was gonna get some money out of it,
and they put it on the monitor.
And when they put it on the monitor,
they were looking to place me,
to make sure that I had no way out,
to place me within the spot
that the victim was hurt.
They wanted to place
me there with the phone
by tracing it, but while they ran it,
new evidence were found,
which were naked pictures
of my baby sister, and then I was like,
"Holy shit!
"This guy is telling the truth."
So, by my third court date, I go in,
and the D.A. did something
that they never do
to nobody, if anybody knows
what I'm talking about,
that D.A. just sits there and watches you,
and doesn't say a thing,
and just convicts you
and gives you your time.
Well this D.A. actually gets up,
walks over to me, and says,
"Mr.Michaels, you know the only difference
"between me and you today is?
"Is I would have killed
that motherfucker."
And I was like, "Whoa!"
That's crazy like, the D.A.
never says no shit like that.
But he says,
"The only reason why we're
giving you time today is,
"because you could've
handled it differently.
"But, you really hurt that guy."
And I really did, and unfortunately,
he didn't die but. (chuckles)
I'm sorry, all I can
do is pray for the guy,
and hope that he makes better decisions
along down the line, but.
So then, he comes at me.
"Well, there's a new deal on the table,
"and that's 20 years without life."
And, I look over at my wife,
she's crying but she was happy
because I'm not gonna spend
the rest of my life in prison.
I signed the 20 years,
and I ended up doing 15 out of those 20,
because I went from an all-out church boy,
to now getting introduced to prison life,
which now I'm all tatted up,
and I've learned the bad
way of life you could say
because I didn't learn anything good
because when you go to prison,
you start to do things
that you don't want to,
and that's why I ended
up doing 15 instead of 10
because it was my first conviction,
and I ended up catching five years
for three institutional stabbings.
And sometimes you have to do that.
If anybody knows anything about prison,
like when it comes to your
time to putting in your work,
you gotta put it in.
Even though you don't want to,
it's something that you have to do.
Sometimes, it's kinda
fun participating in it,
but my last five years were segregated.
I was in Corc in SHU, which
they call it The Green Wall,
the hardest prison you could go to.
It's the hardest ad seg, ASU,
that you could possibly go to.
It's all concrete.
The only person you see is the deputy,
and sometimes you're so freaking bored
when they're walking by,
you need somebody to
talk to so you're like,
"Hey, what's up deputy, yeah
yeah yeah, how you doin'?"
You know, trying to get any words at him
because you're in that
block, concrete room,
that little slot, they
really make you feel like
you're in segregated ICU.
And so, I would do that, and
I spent my time working out
and doing that but,
I did those 15.
It was crazy because when I got out,
I got out and,
it was different.
Everything changed on me, like
now I have a gang background.
I've acquired a lot of
different new hobbies,
as in drug addiction.
I have became something that
I didn't really want to be,
but I wouldn't change the decision I made
because I mean, I felt
that it was something good.
That I did good for my little baby sister
because otherwise, she would
have went another route
within her life.
She would have been stuck
with this 30 year old man
that had nothing going on for himself.
- [Interviewer] Did he ever molest her?
- Yeah, yeah, he molested her,
and that's why I did that was because,
before I caught that case, he
was taking advantage of her
while we were gone, me
and my mom and stuff.
And him and his girlfriend
would babysit my sister.
And while we were all gone,
thinking everything's okay,
he was having sex with her.
He was manipulating her,
and he made her fall in love with him,
and by that time, she's
thinking this guy loves her,
and she had no idea.
I mean, the girl was only 13.
She was only 13 years old
when all of this is going on.
Now she don't talk to me.
I wish she would and know
that I'm not mad at her,
but now she's just, I think
embarrassed or whatever.
He kinda messed up her head,
and I feel bad for her,
but, it's something we both
gotta live with I guess.
But yeah, that was how my story ended up.
Now I gotta live with this,
and I got to turn it positive
because I don't know,
we're self-destructive to ourselves,
and getting addicted to all
these drugs and stuff like that,
it goes nowhere.
You end up with nothing
because before this,
I was a working guy.
Everything I did was involved in church,
and then, like I said, I
went to prison, and it just.
I started learning how to deal drugs,
going in the prison system,
how to make money within the system.
If anybody knows confirmation,
in prison we collect confirmation numbers.
We get the dope through freaking guys',
people bring it in through
their ass or whatever they do,
and they bring it in to us,
the ones that have the back job,
and we break it up in the prison system,
and we sell little specs
for a hundred bucks.
And when somebody wants to buy something,
they got to come with
a confirmation number.
A confirmation number,
which is the green dots,
that's how we make money in prison,
and we send it out to our family members,
and then they ship it back in to us,
put it on our books or whatever,
and that's how we buy things.
That's how we get cellphones,
that's how the system moves,
that's how we become
productive, by being lockdown
because you want to be able to,
being a man, want to be
able to still provide
for your family.
So, whatever way, we always find a way,
and that's how I did it,
was start trafficking heroin
throughout the system.
I was the dope man in the system,
and it was kinda cool because
I was making a lot of money.
I was making a lot of money within.
I'll get a quarter ounce and make $12,000
within a month period,
and it was cool,
but, still, that money went so quick.
When I got out, I had a house,
I had my cars,
and everything was there.
It was successful to me, and
I met a lot of different type
of people, and I came out
thinking I could be the same guy
that I was in prison because now,
I now all these connections,
where I could be the dope man.
And if you guys look me
up, I was busted for drugs,
and they considered me the kingpin
when I was on the streets,
and I thought that was funny
because when I got busted for that,
they said I had a drug ring,
which wasn't a drug ring.
I was just selling dope.
Now I learned how to do that,
and I was able to provide
to my family within that, but
it turned into something else
because, if anybody knows
about the dope game,
you're still breaking the law,
you're still doing this and that,
and I started off okay.
And then, people started dying on me
as in, as we went along down,
I'm trying to write this
story and keep it on track.
When I got out, we started,
and I met a few people.
We met up from the prison system.
They happened to be somebodies,
and they started providing
drugs to me at a cheap price,
which I was in Victorville,
and I started moving and trafficking it,
and within that time, I guess I was stupid
because I was allowing a lot
of traffic to come to my house.
A lot of people were coming to my house,
and the cops were monitoring me now,
and I had no idea.
I had no idea the feds,
when they're watching you or
the cops are watching you,
that they actually have the
mailman as a undercover,
while you think it's
just a mailman coming by
to drop off mail, no, that's the cops.
And they're freaking good
at what they freaking do
because I honestly didn't
believe some of my friends.
They're like, "Hey Tony,
you need to freaking stop
"using your phone line
because they're watching you."
And I was like, "Nah, that's impossible.
"That's only in movies."
Sure enough, my door gets kicked in again,
and the cops come in,
and they have pictures of
everybody that came to my house,
everybody, even myself.
They had me looking like I
was a freakin' supermodel
or something, there was so many pictures.
I'm like, "God damn, where
they get these pictures?"
And sure enough, I find
out that the mailman,
the guy that was putting up the signs,
the guy that was just walking
down the street with the dog,
they were all the cops.
And they ended up taking me down for that,
and if anybody wants to
know if this story's true,
just look up, Tony Michaels
online under F77593.
That's my prison number,
and I do have a great bodily injury,
to create great bodily harm with a weapon,
and I do have a drug trafficking charge
because when they caught me,
they caught me with a
kilo and a half of heroin
and $5,000 in my pocket,
and that's all online right now with that.
That being said, is there
any more questions on that?
- [Interviewer] So where
is your life today?
- How my life is today, it's going better.
I'm trying to get on track with it.
I'm trying to bounce back
from doing what I did.
Now I'm trying to do it
different, trying to stay sober,
and I'm trying to just
get my life back in.
By doing that, I'm trying to figure out
some hobbies like working out.
I guess I gotta get back to
the way I used to live which,
that's kinda forgotten,
because it's been so long.
Because I did do 15
years and just got out.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- I'm 33 years old,
and when that happened,
I was 18, going to 19.
I was young,
and now it's kinda hard but,
at the same time, who can say it's hard
if you're not taking that first step?
That's what we have the tendency of doing.
We're saying we're gonna do
this, we're gonna do that,
but, we never take that first step.
And that's what I gotta do now.
I gotta man up, leave the bullshit alone,
stop associating myself with the people
because within that, I
don't know if anybody knows
who Joel Osteen is, he says
it on one of his sermons.
He says, "If you wanna
"be a chicken, you can be a chicken,
"but if you wanna soar like a eagle,
"you can soar like an eagle,
"it's who you surround yourself with."
You know what I mean?
If you wanna kick it
with some freakin' bums,
best know you're gonna become a bum.
You know what I mean?
Well this is my advice to everybody is,
if you wanna hang out and
you wanna do better in life,
start hanging out with winners,
people that are doing something,
people that have something
going on for themselves.
Maybe you're not doing it,
but, surround yourselves
with those people,
and eventually, you will be doing that.
Eventually, you will have
that car or whatever it is
that your goals are in
life, that can be it.
Because Kobe Bryant, I
know he just passed away,
but Kobe said something
important that affected me
in life, which was,
when you feel tired, when
you feel like giving up,
when you feel you like you
don't even wanna do it anymore,
that's when you do it.
That's when you go forward
and you push yourself,
and you get that
accomplished because that's
when your dreams will come true,
and that's what he said.
When you feel tired and
feel like not doing it,
get up and do it,
and that's when you'll start
seeing your dreams come true.
And it's true, you know?
When I feel like giving up or I feel like,
just saying "Fuck it."
and taking that hit, and
getting high again or,
whatever it is that I feel like doing,
and that's just throwing in the towel
but, I need to push forward
and get on with my life,
and just, stop letting my past
because my father wasn't
there or whatever,
because a lot of us do that,
is we let our past affect us today.
We gotta just leave that alone.
Stop wasting your todays in
your problems of yesterday.
You know what I mean?
Because we can't do that no more.
We got to forget about
it, you know what I mean?
Just leave that alone, and
just use that as the past,
and move on forward,
and live with your life.
Like myself, now I don't talk to people
when I say, "Oh, I went to
prison 15 years, I'm badass."
Nah, it's even about that anymore.
I use it as a past experience
as to, you know what?
Maybe you don't want to go that route
because I went that route,
and there's nothing in it.
And that's what I do.
Now it's just a testimony for me.
Now, it's only for somebody
that's hurting out there,
and that's what I try to do.
I try to make positive at it because
damn, we can't just stay in motion,
let our past affect us anymore.
We gotta go forward.
And it was unfortunate
that my dad wasn't there
but, whatever he's going through,
or whatever he had to, he went to prison,
and he did his time.
Doesn't mean I got to do that
and be absent to my children.
I believe that it's gonna get better
because I don't wanna put
no God's name or anything,
because who knows who's
watching this video.
They can be Muslim or
whatever, and that's not me.
We're all thriving for the same thing,
just for peace and tranquility
and bettering our lives,
and that's why we believe in a God.
- [Interviewer] So are
you still using heroin?
- No, I quit heroin.
I've been two years off it already.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get off it?
- How'd I get off it?
To be honest, I got
addicted to something else,
which was weed, marijuana.
I smoke weed, but I look at
it like it's legal and...
Yeah, it's bad but, at the same time,
I believe it's not as
bad as heroin, you know?
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- I have a daughter.
I have two daughters.
Two daughters, and it's
unfortunate that I was absent
from my 15 year old
daughter and well shit,
yeah, she's going 17 now.
She's 17.
Natalie, I'm proud of her.
I love her.
It's just, I don't wanna
go into her life right now
because I feel like I'm gonna shock her
because she's so smart and
she's doing things for herself,
which I don't wanna, I don't
know if I'm doing bad for her
or I'm doing good, but I feel
that if I come into her life,
she's gonna look at me like,
"Dude, what's up with my dad?"
Like I got tatted up.
I'm not really doing too good,
so I don't know how to
explain to her that I'm scared
to let her know me because
of the decisions that I made,
and it scares me but,
eventually, I wanna talk to her.
And I'm waiting for her to
just get through schooling
and she continues on the right path.
Because yeah, she's doing
good, and I'm hoping, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so
much for talking with me, Tony.
- Okay, you're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- [Tony] Can I get one more of these?